Elements hundred and ten darmstadtium
was discovered here in dumb start where
I'm standing in the snow and it was
discovered in the Institute GSI the
Society for heavy iron research which
you can see behind me and I'm really
excited to be here place where elements
have been discovered
darmstadtium like the other of these
very heavy elements that were discovered
here was made by fusing metal atoms from
light transition metals iron copper and
so on in Toledo basement the first thing
you have to do is to decide which metal
you want to begin with because you have
to load that in into the ion chamber the
start of your accelerator some of that
is evaporated and it goes into a long
tube and it's accelerated up and it goes
up to speeds of nearly one tenth of the
speed of light if it goes too fast when
you create a new element it'll fall to
bits if it goes too slow you'll never
make the elephant and it goes down a
long tube through the wall into a new
chamber and in the chamber there's a LED
target whizzing round so it doesn't get
too hot past the target out to the back
of the target every so often comes just
one or two atoms of the elements you
want and they go into a separator and
the separator gets rid of all the other
ions and takes the elements you want to
the detector detectors a lovely shiny
piece of silicon in this special
detector developed here in dumb start
and then you sit in the control room and
watch the results and then after the
coffee-room to decide what name you're
going to give it well I think it's a
great name there was a toke that they
were going to call the element Vic's
house um after the suburb of dumb start
fixin house and where we the Institute
is actually situated
you can't build an institute like this
in the middle of a town but they they in
the end decided on darmstadtium in this
case we decided to name it after the
city where TSI is located and system
start and we called it darmstadtium
there's a story in Wikipedia that
because one one oh one hundred and ten
is the emergency number for the police
here in Germany we're done studies that
they thought of calling the element
palladium after the police but I think
that's just a tall story